[Music]
our friend the great one Mark Levin just
literally lighting up House Oversight
Committee chairman trey Gowdy after the
congressman praised the FBI for spying
and the Trump campaign congressman Gowdy
what's happened to you take a listen and
he's drawing a conclusion nothing wrong
with this FBI informant the FBI did
exactly what the FBI is supposed to
doing the American people agree
and of course trey Gowdy knows that the
American people agree because nobody
speaks for the American people like trey
Gowdy did they have an informant aka spy
at the DNC to chase down the Russians
who are hacking the DNC's emails know if
they're trying to protect us and the
candidates in the election from the
Russians as we pointed out last week why
weren't there informants in Jill Stein's
campaign or Hillary Clinton's campaign
or Bernie Sanders campaign boom
checkmate here with us deputy assistant
of the president Fox News national
security strategist Sebastian Gorka
former Secret Service agent NRA
contributed dan bond Geno author next
month July coming the Russian hoax the
illicit scheme to clear Hillary Clinton
and breeam Donald Trump you know how
miss Fox News legal analyst Greg Jarrett
I have an important question for you let
me start though with Dan bond Geno
responding to the great one and trey
Gowdy why weren't their spies in anyone
else's campaign great question how is it
that is greg has pointed out the
interrogatories in Great Britain by
Christopher Steele he said oh it's raw
intelligence maybe 50/50 used to get
FISA warrants on American citizens one
that happened to be in the Trump
campaign yeah they weren't spies another
campaign Shawn because they were spying
on Trump they will hurt spying on the
Russians you know listen this is this is
I don't know what a Trey Gaudi wafted a
little of that swamp air I'm never sold
he never saw the documents how could he
make never so many documents but he made
a comment so irresponsible and
reprehensible Shawn he said Americans
should be confident the FBI worked the
cases they should have really that why
they hide the case from congressional
oversight they hid it
this is all out there Freddie went to
sea for eight months when they were
supposed to brief them quarterly while
they simultaneously Shaun leaked the
existence of the case to the New York
Times and then leaked later the
conversation about Mike Flynn to the
Washington everything is new European we
know it's not everything New York Times
reporting is now boomerang even within
their own reports you know they just
really you know implement like spies the
information that they don't mean to
reveal dr. Gorka let me ask you about
this McCabe secret memo that I talked
about again I think that is now
backfiring on them as well absolutely
it's the ultimate boomerang all of this
that look at that video of Ben Rhodes
and then you will understand everything
the night of the election Ben Rhodes the
master of lying has no words to explain
the loss of Hillary Clinton this is why
they were doing what they were doing she
had to win at all costs that's why an
intelligence asset whatever you want to
call it was put into the Trump campaign
then let's not argue about whether it's
a spy or an informant because that's
irrelevant
sure we need to know one answer to one
question why was the operation started
we still don't know we can an Australian
ambassador a professor in the UK now a
Maltese professor in in Rome it stinks
to high heaven and trey Gowdy we know
some read the documents look at the
fixes in for Hillary she didn't obstruct
justice but Martha Stewart did okay do
we have equal justice under the law look
at unmasking look at surveillance look
at leaking intelligence fixing Hillary
campaign you know FISA abuse all of this
is you know it's rotting from the head
down and the FBI rank and file are going
to expose it this dovetails nicely this
whole McCabe memo and first of all the
president could fire Comey because he
didn't like his did the the color of his
socks it he doesn't need a reason but
when you add that to what John Solomon
is now that what is he is saying FBI
documents bring it right to the Obama
administration absolutely and I've seen
than I can say Peter struck sent a text
message to his mistress Lisa page on
August 5th
he had just signed the documents opening
the Trump Russia collusion case in in
that text he says the White House is
running this the chronology of the fence
tells you what happened so we're gonna
see a Peter struck memo the guy that
wrote the exoneration of Hillary right
before the investigation signed the
papers a guide the Trump investor it
immediately began ran over to the White
House is running this what does that
mean from the Obama White House of
course it meant President Obama who's
being briefed all the time by John
Brennan the CIA director who is the
instigator of the phony dossier another
big reveal by the New York Times they
didn't mean oh for the FBI to interview
this Australian that meant and it was
drinking with papahana Fowler it had to
be negotiated by our State Department
that means john kerry knew that means
that probably obama knew that's another
sign pointing to enough barack obama and
company on June 20th Steele writes his
phony fictitious dossier first memo he
immediately calls the FBI the FBI two
weeks later flies to London at Orbis
headquarters and meets with Christopher
Steele who tells them all about Trump
Russia collusion that was phony evidence
three weeks later the FBI opens its
investigation and only there after they
start looking into Papadopoulou and now
we know the timeline is off to as it
started in the spring alright last word
from both Dan and dr. Gorka Dan Shawn I
think the next shooter drop is the
information about you know Russian dirt
on Hillary was clearly pulled out of the
campaign by the FBI who pushed it in
there that's going to be the next shoe
to drop
okay paying close attention and dr.
korkor the suspect number one is John
Brennan and he wouldn't have moved a
muscle
unless Obama knew as well boom okay it's
all collapsing and they're turning
on each other do you notice that cabe
call me it's all gonna be a circular
firing squad it is and Peter struck and
Lisa Paige Oh can't wait